thunder what was the first script that
you were ever commissioned to write
can you recall huh the uh
the first script i was ever commissioned
to write not not an option
you know i'd written a couple of scripts
on my own that got optioned the first
script i was ever actually hired to
write
was for the asylum it was a film called
200 miles per hour
which was basically a car racing movie
and the asylum they distribute sort of
what they call mock busters
mockbusters and b movies low budget
stuff
right right okay so
was that script easier to write than one
that you
thought of on your own and were the
driving
engine behind was it easier to know that
people were counting on you
and that there possibly could be money
behind it or is it harder
to be your own bandleader
i think it's harder in a lot of ways
it's harder to write your own script
because there's nobody
there's nobody providing parameters
guidelines
so you know you can do anything
and that means you have to control
yourself you have to narrow yourself
down
every day you have to be your own sort
of critic
and and that that requires thinking in a
lot of different ways
whereas when you know you have an
approved storyline and this is what they
want
and you just have to deliver it uh in in
some ways that
that's a lot easier because there are
there are fewer decisions to make
at every turn on the other hand that
that first script i had to write 200
miles per hour
from the day they gave me the assignment
that needed to be done in 10 days
so and i i'd never written a feature
script that quickly before
so that was that was an interesting
challenge i was basically chained to my
computer 12 hours a day
so what are some tips that you can share
in terms of
not finding reasons to get up from the
desk and and making excuses because i'm
sure
that might have been easier knowing that
there was this ticking clock
yeah when when there's a deadline it's a
lot easier to
force yourself to just stay there you
know you know how many pages you have to
write on
average each day to to be finished by
the
the date they set for you and if you're
not making
that quota you know you're screwing up
and
someday you're going to be up 24 hours
straight trying to make up for it so
it's it's uh
when you've got a deadline it's a lot
easier to to discipline yourself
at the same time my in my experience uh
screenwriting is eighty percent
surfing the web doing dishes walking the
dog
all the while hopefully you're thinking
about what you're going to be writing
and then
20 percent of the time you're actually
typing away
so speaking of that when you are your
own
band leader for lack of a better word
what are some tips that you can use to
keep yourself again in that chair
or is it all part of this process of
just observation
you know uh honestly i i think it's a
it's a double-edged sword because you
can justify
a lot of goofing off during the writing
process
as letting the creative juices flow and
build and
letting your mind wander a bit you know
the truth is
story not so much storytelling but story
creating
happens in the subconscious
and sometimes if you just sit there and
you stare at a computer screen or you
stare at a blank piece of paper
waiting for words to come it's a more
forced artificial process whereas
you know sitting in a park
um watching people interact
you might get an idea for something
on the other hand you can waste way too
much time doing that
so it's a double-edged sword and you
have to find a way
to to discipline yourself and you know
that's going to be different
for everybody the way i do it is to set
myself a page quote i have to write a
certain number of pages each day
and if i've wasted time on the internet
or in pointless facebook debates which
seem to occupy an increasingly
large amount of time
you know i don't let myself get up i
don't let myself go to bed or
whatever i don't leave the computer
until i've reached that quota so that's
that that's really the only way for me
that's uh
that's really proven to be effective
because otherwise you know i'll write
one good little bit and i'll be all
proud of myself
and then i'll go do something else and
at the end of the day i discovered that
well that was a good bit but it was only
half a page
and now i have 10 pages to write
tomorrow instead of five
so so keeping to a daily quota is really
something that's
been effective for me are you a harsh
task master for yourself are you sort of
like one of these
lenient parents real gentle with
yourself and
again it depends on whether i'm i'm
writing on deadline
if i have a deadline and i know when
something has to be done and i'm
it's a paying job i'm a pretty harsh
taskmaster
when i'm writing a spec script for
myself i tend to go a bit easier
on myself on the theory that
creativity is what's most important here
i'm not on deadline and i don't need to
meet somebody else's
schedule and i should just let it flow
but again that's
you know that's really just
self-justification and there's a huge
amount i think there's a huge amount of
laziness
involved in being a screenwriter to be
honest with you
we had a comment come in from brianna
and she wrote i like
screenwriting but my dialogue always
seems boring and i never know what to
add
how can you spice up dialogue
what's your reaction to that
dialogue you know writing good dialogue
is um
it's a bit of an arcane art um
as as much as screenwriting as a craft
there's there's there's a dark art to it
and sometimes these things just have to
come to you
one one good trick is to
try and keep your sentences as short as
possible
which forces you to write in a in a
punchier
fashion um that's that's something that
uh
that i guess i learned from my
journalist father um
although honestly i tend to break that
rule a lot so i'm
probably a bit hypocritical there um
maybe you're rebelling
maybe maybe i did that enough
you know there's an old rule that you
leave you enter a scene as late as
possible
and you leave it as early as possible
and you make sure
that you hit the main point of that
scene and if you keep that in mind that
will also tend to focus your
dialogue remembering who your characters
are just trying to
i mean what i do is i tend to be
the hero you know in uh in the first
sharknado i didn't know ayan's earing
was gonna
play finn um so that character was just
me what would i do
if i were thrown into this insane
situation
um and so then i i write
as my ideal self what would i like to
say
uh in in that situation what would i
like to do
um you know because in in everyday life
we all have these moments where somebody
says something to us and we just go
and we don't know what to say and then
10 minutes later it comes to you
what you should have said to that person
and the beauty of screenwriting is you
can wait 10 minutes until you figure it
out
and then write it down so if you're
writing a villain character
where do you go because we all have you
know
still cliche the dark and the light but
right so where do you go
they're they're i found two ways to
write
villain characters and mind you well
i've noticed an interesting thing about
my own writing and this is something i'm
just sort of discovering
is that i tend to not write villains i
don't like bad people
so my villains tend to be
external forces a tornado full of sharks
zombies
an enemy ship um hostile aliens
things that you don't really have to get
to know
and that's something that i've just
recently been discovering about myself
and thinking that you know
i've got to sort of explore
writing more interesting uh personal
evil characters and how does one do that
obviously one can simply take all of
your
anger and self-justification and things
that happen to you in the world and sort
of
bundle them and hang on to them and
focus them into this character
and the other way to do it is to think
of the people
in your life who are pissing you off the
most
and then imbue your bad guy characters
with some of those traits but at the
same time you have to remember that
everybody even the most evil character
i'm sure even adolf hitler
thought he was doing something right um
and so you have to be able to establish
a logic and a self-justification
for any bad guy for them to have
internal credibility
and because if they don't have that they
just become cartoon
dick dastardly characters you know
twirling their mustaches
and i'm actually writing one of those
right now and i'm trying one of my
challenges is
how do i justify this character to
himself
we had a comment come in from anonymous
i know
who that is anonymous in seattle yeah oh
then i don't
hello i have an idea for a movie but
nobody gives me a chance well
i can't hear that no um
uh you know it's funny since sharknado i
get a lot of people on
on twitter and facebook
and contacting me through my website
saying hey i've got this great idea for
a movie and i think you'd love it
you know and and there are so many legal
reasons why
you can't hear them you know and and so
so many people have such similar ideas
especially since sharknado because
it just gives rise to this mashup title
thing
you know and barricane and
what was the other one i really liked
snail nato it'll it'll be slow moving so
there'll be plenty of time for character
development
um you know and you get literally
dozens if not hundreds of people sending
the same idea
um you know and you can get in a lot of
trouble that way
i've seen people people have actually
sent
tried to send me ideas that i've already
had
and okay well now if they see
this bit in a movie i write they're
going to say hey you stole that from me
no i didn't it's just there are there
are similar ideas out there
so so it's it's a tricky thing at the
same time
you want to be open to the possibility
that somebody out there
you know some undiscovered talent really
does have a great idea
um and and so maybe you should uh
explore that um
and even even then it's a it's a tricky
proposition well i'm wondering if
anonymous
was more keeping in the vein of like i
have these ideas but no one
how do i break in yeah i think well
that's that's an awfully good question
because i s
you know i've been trying to break in
for 20 odd years
and it's been a it's been sort of a slow
moving process
you know they'll tell you get an agent
but of course that's even
harder these days than than getting into
some production companies
there's no i mean there are a couple of
tried and true parameters and they don't
work very well there are writing
contests
there's a thing called inktip.com
where they will that you can
list an idea not an idea a synopsis
in their quarterly or monthly
newsletter that they distribute to
producers and
early on i had a little uh success with
that
and at the same time there they have a
a weekly email blast that you can get
and
there will be a couple of producers that
you can submit ideas to who are looking
for specific things they'll tell you
what they
are looking for and you can submit to
that
you can write query letters to agents
you can write query letters to producers
really the best advice though is to come
to la
and network there's really
no substitute for it and most writers
hate doing that we're not
sales people to this day i mean we're
sitting in my manager's office
and every time i come into this room
he's telling me look you've got to be a
salesman
and i'm like i'm not a salesman i'm a
screenwriter damn it
um but
that's the nature of the beast um and
you have to learn to do that
uh as distasteful as it is
um you know and if you have the right
kind of personality and you can go to a
hollywood party or
you know an off off off hollywood party
but somebody might be there
you know the the old uh the old saw
about six degrees of separation
everybody knows somebody who knows
somebody
who knows somebody who can do something
for you and
the more people you meet the better your
odds become it's so it's a mathematical
process
eventually you're going to strike
somebody who can help you out
and and then the final thing and this
worked for me early on in my career when
i first came to la
is to find shows that really talk to you
things you really like whether they're
movies or tv shows
and just send an email or send a letter
you know you can look it up in the
hollywood reporter or variety or there
there are so many online resources now
find a person don't hit the star
don't hit the top level executive
producer but find somebody who works on
that show
that the public at large doesn't know
and send them a personal contact that
worked for me a couple of times there
was a
tv show when i came out here called the
war of the worlds the tv series it only
lasted a year or two
but i really liked it and so i
i called up their production office and
i asked to speak to one of the
i got the names of one of the producers
and i asked to speak to him
you know and i had to go through three
different levels of assistance
and finally they said write us a letter
send us something
and so i sent them my student film but
eventually he
called me back and he said hey i like
what you did here why don't you come in
and talk and he didn't hire me that day
he didn't
to this day he hasn't hired me but we've
become great friends and he's sort of
been a mentor for me over the years
another situation after die hard in the
hunt for red october
i was in love with the work that john
mctiernan was doing as a director
and so i called his office and tried to
speak to him and of course i never got
to john mctiernan
but i spoke to his assistant and
she and i sort of started a conversation
and i would call back every two weeks
saying hey do you think
he could look at my film and then i sent
my film and hey has he looked at my film
yet
you know and i didn't bug them i did it
every couple of weeks and eventually
said she said why don't you come in and
talk to me so i went in and i had lunch
with her and i got to sit in um
sitting on dailies one day during hunt
for red october
and she and i became great friends and
she she actually is the one who put me
in touch with the first producer
who uh who hired me to direct something
so you never know where these
opportunities are going to
be coming from you just have to be on
the lookout for
anything because there are no there
the front doors are locked you gotta you
gotta crawl in through one of the back
windows
how was it that first when you were
getting ready to go have lunch with that
assistant
back then like were you rehearsing
dialogue
um you know i've never been good at
pitching i can't i can't i can't sit
there and say
okay now picture this that that's that's
what they tell you to do and i'm just no
good at it
i i tell people what my story is and i
hope they can see what i see
but that that that first time i was
going in to meet john mctiernan's
assistant
i was scared out of my mind i remember
driving to
uh i think it was to the paramount lot
um and uh and and the whole day was kind
of a blur i mean i walked into the
office
they were in the middle of shooting hunt
for red october and as i was walking
into the office to meet her alec baldwin
was walking out in his naval uniform
and i was like holy crap um
it's all kind of a blur to be honest um
but somehow once i sat down with her and
it was just me and her
two people having a conversation all
that went away and
i remembered why i was there and i
remembered how much i want to do this
and i talked about um how much i had
liked what mctiernan had done
in die hard and predator and i asked her
how they got their start and
she was actually more than his assistant
she was basically his business partner
um and they had made his first film
together she had produced it
so i was asking her how they did that
and i was telling her about my student
film
and it just became a conversation and
the key to this business
is just really getting to know people
like you know they it's a cliche it's
not what you know it's who you know
and that's true so often
i've had meetings where the whole point
is simply to get to know somebody
they're not going to buy the idea i'm
pitching they're not even in the market
for it
but get to know them establish a
relationship so
six months or a year down the line when
you have an idea that might be right for
them
you can call them up and say hey hi how
are you and they'll say yeah hi how are
you
and then i'll say hey i've got something
that really might work for you
so do you think that over the past 20
years since you've been in la
that that's been the key to yourself
what a depressing thought i've been here
that long
but we've known people that have turned
around and been here less time have
given up
and there's that famous harrison ford
story
you know the 20 years the house all the
room right right right right right
um so is that the the key that the
relationships but also
you must have had work and ideas to back
it up because just being friends with
someone or
having their business card and calling i
don't think is well right the
relationships are key to
to getting your foot in the door and to
getting your work in front of the right
people
but if your work's no good it all the
relationships in the world
usually won't help you not not always
i've seen some truly
bad material produced probably because
of great relationships
but for somebody breaking in
excuse me for somebody breaking in
you've got to have the work you've got
to be able to back up what you say
was there a key decision that you look
back on and say okay this is what led to
then
b c and d and has got me here
yeah when i was six years old my mother
decided that i could stay up late to
watch star trek
and um that that literally
is is where it all started for me
because that show
uh i'm talking about the original star
trek um that show just opened my eyes
to a world other than what i saw in
front of me every day
as a little kid and i think that's where
my imagination really started
to uh to reach out and and see what
what i could envision um
and then somebody gave me a book called
the making of star trek
remind you i was way too young to read
this very dry technical book so i
i went to the picture section and the
very first picture
in the photo section of the making of
star trek
is these uh 1960s
studio technicians doing some sort of
work on the bridge of the enterprise
um it something just clicked
in my head you know i wanted to be mr
spock or captain kirk
but i knew that wasn't real and that was
about the limit of my understanding at
that age
and then here were these real people
working on the bridge of the enterprise
and and something just clicked for me
like there is a way to work on the
enterprise
i can go do that um you know and
over the next five or ten years of
childhood
and adolescence there were a lot of
different things that i thought maybe i
would do when i grew up
but but that always stuck with me
and so and so the key moment was my mom
letting me stay up to watch star
trek you're probably not looking for
that
key moment uh
key moment in my career
you know looking back on it
there were two the first was meeting
john mctiernan's assistant because she
eventually put me in touch
with uh with the producer who would hire
me
uh as my first directing job that job
ended up not going so well it was
actually a disaster
but having that first professional
credit
and having been referred to a working
producer
from somebody else he knew in the
business gave me a certain amount of
credibility
that i was unable to build on and and
develop
further relationships out of that
and then the other moment was for many
many years i had
told myself look if things don't work
out i will
raise money and i will make an
independent film myself
because so much of of this business if
you're a
director primarily less as a writer
because as a writer you just write
something if it's really good people
will see that
if they read it and so the trick is just
getting them to read your script
but as a director you have to direct
something
to prove what you can do and often
shorts
are just you know ignored uh by the
industry to a certain extent
people for some reason it doesn't make a
lot of sense producers
see a well done short and they'll
in their head they'll go oh yeah but
that's just a short
where's your feature and you know most
people don't have features because
they're very expensive to make
and if they're not very expensive they
tend to look like crap
so in the back of my head i always had
this idea that if i didn't break in
eventually and i was never sure what
eventually meant
that i would raise money and make an
independent film
and i should have probably done that
in my late 20s or when i hit 30.
but it took another five or six years
before i finally decided that
none of these almost happened jobs
had ever actually happened and so i
should just
buckle down and do this and so that's
what happened is um
myself and a partner we put together a
business plan we raised 150 000
um and we made a film
and it was that film that uh finally got
david lat one of the partners at the
asylum
to take me seriously even though i'd
known him for 10 years
i'd just been a friend i'd just been
that guy oh yeah that guy
um who wanted to make movies but never
had
so now i had this thing that i could put
in front of and say here look this is
entertaining people watch this and they
enjoy it
and he couldn't deny that um and so
you know he put me in touch with his
director of development and they started
including me when they were looking for
new ideas and
eventually we uh we moved on to making a
film together
so would you say that was your defining
moment when you actually
became a professional because i'm you
know the stephen pressfield model of
that resistance
from the war of art where they say that
uh he
i don't know if you've read the book
it's fantastic i have that okay i have
it
it's one of those things on the shelf
say i've got to read this but
it's important well he talks about the
resistance whether it's from
people around you whether it's from
yourself and
once that artist breaks through that
being so fearful to show that film or
whatever it is that's
stopping them those excuses that's kind
of the moment when they turn
pro so to speak so do you think that was
the moment
when you finally said you know what i've
had
enough trying to almost get this job
i've come close
for some reason i haven't made it i've
always been cut out but this
this time i'm doing it i'm going to have
that thing to put in front of people
and that was the moment that you turned
professional
that you turned that was certainly a
breakthrough
uh deciding to raise money and make an
independent film was certainly a
breakthrough moment for me
i hesitate to say that's when i became a
professional
because it was nearly 10 years before
that i'd been hired
to to direct a film and so i would argue
that you're a professional as soon as
somebody pays you to do what you do
but coming to the conclusion that nobody
was going to do it for me
and i had to make this happen myself
was certainly a the key moment
in getting to where i am today and mind
you where i am today is no great shakes
i mean
maybe sharknado 2 will come out and
people will realize that the first one
wasn't a fluke
and that we actually know what we're
talking about um
and then myself and anthony the director
and
some other people involved will uh will
be taken even more seriously
but that that was the key moment that
led to where i am now and hopefully will
lead to even more
have you looked back at your life and
said what would have happened
if i hadn't talked to the sci-fi channel
about writing the script
hadn't follow through where would i be i
look back at my life
and wish i had made that independent
film five or ten years earlier
because that's that is kind of what
started the ball rolling
and if i had done that a lot earlier i
think
through one means or another i would
have
uh have you know picked up steam
along the same path along the same
timeline as i have
but i'd be 10 years younger and
you know and have more energy and have
more um
not optimism that's not the word i'm
looking for because i've got actually
have a lot of optimism right now
um
this is bad for a writer because now i
don't have the word that i need
um i i wish i wish i had done it sooner
um because i think i would be much
further along now
than i am
um is it blind confidence you know how
in youth
people think there's no way they can
fail
and it's i envy that you don't overthink
it you just say oh yeah i'm going to be
the next whatever
no because i i still think i'm the next
steven spielberg
i still have blind confidence and blind
optimism
um but you know
my manager in particular uh keeps saying
look we've got to take this one step at
a time you did sharknado now we build on
that you do something
like it but more bigger
for lack of a better word and then you
take that and you do something else but
you can't move right on to doing
shakespeare
because nobody's going to take the
writer of sharknado seriously when he
says he wants to do shakespeare
i don't actually want to do shakespeare
but there are there are serious
uh you know genre films that i want to
make that aren't tongue-in-cheek
um and so it frustrates me because i'm
already at the point in my life
where i just want to be doing what i do
um you know and i feel like i've paid my
dues and i've been doing this for a very
long time
um but but you've got to you've got to
put that in check you've got to
take your ego down a notch you barely
have to take your ego out of the
equation
and say okay this is how i am perceived
by the world and by the industry
i have to accept that even though that's
not the sum total of
who i am as a person or as a
professional i have to accept that this
is the way i'm seen now
so how do i build on that to get to
where i want to be
i completely forgot what your question
was
oh wow that's great sorry i got lost in
what you were saying and i forgot my
question too i think
i i was talking about
resistance and the moment that you
realize
that but it sounds like being paid as a
writer
that does give a professional stamp but
there must have been something very
freeing in terms of your
whole process of going out and actually
doing what you were saying
doing what you said you were going to do
that that was that i'm glad you made
that said that phrase because
that that's something that i've
that i've realized is that for many
years i had developed a lot of
connections in the business
and i was telling people that i was a
good writer and director
mainly a director to be honest it's it's
a little frustrating for me that
the success and the public perception
that i've achieved as a result of
sharknado and some of the other smaller
things i've done
is largely as a screenwriter because
i've always seen myself as a director
first in a
screenwriter second so that's kind of
frustrating
but the the phrase doing what i said i
could do
is key because for years and years i'd
been telling people what i could do if
they would just give me a chance
but that required them taking a leap of
faith on me
and why should they do that when they're
at risk every film
any producer makes every film even a
studio makes
they're risking their entire business
model their entire profession
their entire position in the industry on
every project they make
so why on earth should they take a risk
a leap of faith on me
an unproven quantity when they can hire
steven spielberg or james cameron or
ridley scott
or shane black or whoever
that they know is going to deliver and
of course the argument
that the young filmmaker will make is
yes but i have something new that those
guys don't have
they've been doing this we all know what
they can do
that's legitimate to a certain extent
but not from a business standpoint from
a business standpoint you go with
somebody that you know can deliver
you need to be able to show people that
you can do what you say you can do
and if you're just a screenwriter then
that means writing
a really kick-ass script and putting it
in front of somebody
and making the first page so good that
they have to keep reading to page five
and making the first five pages so good
they have to keep reading to page 10
and making the first 10 pages so good
that they never put it down
until they get to the last page and they
have to pick up the phone and call you
as soon as they're done
that's how good your script has to be
and it can't be that good that you
can't think it's that good all your
friends have to read it
and think holy this is the best
thing i've ever read
can i say that on you yeah please we're
on the internet right yeah yeah please
we'll answer it for the rest okay
and uh and then your friends have to
show it to their friends
and people who don't even know you have
to read this and think this is the best
thing
i've ever read i can't wait to see this
on television or in the movies
and when you have a script that's
getting that kind of reaction from your
friends
then you can walk into somebody's door
and say
here this is what i can do read this and
you will hire me
and you'll have that confidence to go
into the room
and exude that and
if you have that confidence people will
read that first page
if you walk into somebody's office and
you feel that way about your material
and you know without a shadow of a doubt
that this is a great script that gets
across to people
and they'll read your first page but if
your first page is amateurishly written
they're going to stop right there
somebody sent me a great idea and it was
one of the few times
in the last year where somebody
contacted me said hey i have this idea
for
a movie i've written a script would you
read it and the the pitch
uh which they actually broke the rules
and they sent me the pitch
in the very first email so that i hadn't
you know i would have had to
stop reading and you know to not have
been exposed to the idea
unfortunately it was not an idea i
already had um
but it was an interesting idea and so i
said
sure send me the script and you know we
did a release form and
they sent me the script and i got the
script and i was really excited to read
it
and the first page i opened it up and it
wasn't even formatted properly
um and i read the first page and and
they weren't writing in proper sentences
and i had to slog through this thing to
figure out what they were trying to say
and i gave up after a couple of pages
because they just
they'd abused me basically they'd stolen
my time they'd wasted my time
on something that wasn't a professional
product that could never be produced
in its current state and maybe if i had
forced myself to read the whole script
there would have been a nugget in there
that was a great idea and with some work
you know i could have pounded the script
into shape
and tried to do something with it but
who has that time
and who knows you could get to the end
of this 120 page script it takes you two
hours out of a very busy day
and you get to the end they could all
have been crap
even even though that one sentence pitch
they sent me was a good idea
so you got to be sure and you can't just
read it yourself and think it's great
other people have to be telling you it's
great
as a director you have even a tougher
road than as a screenwriter
because you can't just sit by yourself
and create something and show it to
somebody and be
and impress them you have to be able to
do what you say you can do
and for a director that means putting
together a lot of people
and even for a cheap film a lot of money
relatively speaking
and a lot of time i mean making a
feature film is a
is an investment of six months to two
years
out of your life um and during that time
you have to figure out how to live too
so that's you know that's a harder road
to host so to speak
and somehow you have to find a way to do
that
because just telling somebody you have a
great idea just describing it to them
even you know if you're a good artist if
you can draw
that that will help a lot because you
can do your own storyboards
you can maybe even do them in color you
can do a graphic novel a comic book
even if it doesn't get published you can
put it in front of somebody
and say here this is what my movie would
be
and that can help and if it's really
great if it's really cool
maybe they'll take a chance on you more
likely they'll say that's really cool
we're going to buy the rights from this
and we'll hire somebody else to make it
um so going out and finding a way to
make a feature
and finding a way to make a feature
that's good
on whatever you're able to raise so
don't go out and raise
you know fifty thousand dollars and make
star wars because it's gonna look like
crap it's gonna look you know like
never mind what it's gonna look like but
find a subject matter that you can do
well
on whatever amount of money you're able
to put together
and if it means two people sitting in a
room talking then
write and then create the most amazing
interesting wonderful two people sitting
in a room talking film you can do
you know anybody almost anybody
these days with the technology that's
available to us
can make a well-produced film of two
people sitting in a table talking
and if you can find a way to make that
interesting
you might impress somebody and they
might say okay
we're not going to give you a fifty
million dollars but
here's two hundred thousand dollars go
make
three people sitting in a room talking
you know go make two people sitting in a
park
talking go make something
that will you'll have a bit better
opportunity to show what you can do
and that's that's all i've done is step
by step i've made slightly better
and better bigger and bigger films and
it was because of those
you know these films i made for the
asylum they technically they were
mockbusters i mean i didn't think of
them that way
i'm not trying to rip off
other people's movies that doesn't
interest me in the slightest and i'm not
trying to
satirize them
the idea of the mockbuster from the
asylums
playbook is not so much to satirize the
individual project but to satirize the
idea
that 200 million dollars is required to
make an entertaining movie
it's not and so for 200
000 or 300 or 350 000
i made a couple of movies for them
that were you know incrementally bigger
and better
than the independent film i'd made that
got me those jobs
and it was the fact that i had done one
of these films for them
well i delivered the script that they
wanted
i delivered it on time i was
relatively easy to work with during the
development process i don't know if the
director of development would
agree with me 100 on that because you
know any creative
people are going to have clashes
but in the end i remember that they're
the ones paying the bills and they
understand what their market is so i
give them what they want
and then i go out and i make the best
film i possibly can on the
money they give me and i put together
the best team of people
people who aren't going to say oh it's
only a 200 000
crappy asylum mockbuster they're going
to say we're going to make this the best
battleship movie we can or the best
alien planet movie we can or the best
zombie film we can
given the resources available to us
and it was the fact that i had done that
and delivered to them
what they needed and something that
showed i actually cared about the
material
and that i had some intelligence and i
had some style
it was that that made them come to me
and say we want you to write a movie
called shark storm
and for me to be in a position to say no
why would i want to write a movie called
shark storm
haven't we had enough dumb shark movies
and they went away and said all right
we'll find somebody else to do it. and
then a month later they came back to me
and they said what we really want you to
do
is write a movie called sharknado and i
said that's the most ridiculous thing
i've ever heard
and if i can write it that way then sure
i'll do it i'd love to do it
and thank god they said yes it's okay to
be ridiculous on a movie called
sharknado
you know and from there in the last two
years
i've had some modicum of success that
hopefully now is leading to bigger and
better things
but it's all because step by step i
proved that i was
i was reliable that i could do what they
needed me to do
and i only got that opportunity because
i'd done what i said i could do
i went out i raised the money i made
this film
and instead of just saying take a chance
on me i said here this is what i can do
and i can do it for you
staying on the theme of mockbusters do
you have any tips on writing sort of
outrageous unbelievable moments
in a scene but having the actors remain
within that reality
well that that's the key to to something
like sharknado is
is writing outrageous things and having
the the characters
stay planted in the reality
um and that's the that's the narrow line
we had to walk on that i did it on
sharknado and i think one of the reasons
that they really wanted me to do
sharknado is i had done exactly that
on my independent film mutant vampire
zombies from the hood
um is that i had written a lot of
ridiculous stuff
but the characters remain remained
planted in
the reality they were in you know if the
actors start winking at the camera
um i didn't do that right it should have
been if the actors start winking at the
camera
um it it just strays into farce
and unless you're really really funny
that will fall flat on the other hand if
you play it too
seriously and you're it's not self-aware
enough
to know what it is then that falls flat
um and i think the reason that um that
sharknado
connected the way it did
is that a lot of these kinds of movies
with the crazy
mash-up titles and the insane premises
have been played completely straight or
completely winking at the camera
and and what we tried to do with
sharknado was was walk that line
um where the characters are
enmeshed in the reality no matter how
ridiculous the reality is
but the filmmakers are saying to the
audience
we know how ridiculous this is but isn't
it fun
when i wrote when i wrote sharknado all
i really did
was i put myself in that situation
they said okay a tornado full of sharks
this is what you have to write a movie
about so okay how do we get
a tornado full of sharks i actually took
a fairly logical realistic approach to
it how would we get
a tornado full of sharks well tornadoes
can spin off
from hurricanes and there are documented
cases of fish being sucked up
into the air by tornadoes and
waterspouts that form over the ocean
okay so now i have a logical basis
tornadoes spin off hurricanes over the
ocean
there's a lot happen to be a large
concentration of sharks in that area
that
water spouts suck up the sharks and now
we have
sharknados okay well that's that's step
one
step two was creating a larger
environment for that to take place in
what would happen
if a hurricane hit los angeles so i had
a realistic disaster movie
because with global warming and
everything it's it's
if not likely it's at least
less unlikely that a hurricane could hit
los angeles
and los angeles is a city that floods if
it rains for five minutes
so what would happen if a hurricane hit
here so that was a
that was a reasonable realistic disaster
moving
so i took that and i put a character in
it
that was me basically i'm the hero in
that movie what would i do if i was in
this situation
well you know i've been reading science
fiction my whole life so i've always
been prepared for the zombie apocalypse
or for a comet to hit the earth or what
have you and i've always
you know even if i don't have a huge
compound somewhere
waiting for the end of the world i've at
least thought about what i would do in a
disaster scenario
so okay i took some of that and put that
in there
and gave finn my my motto semper paratus
which means always prepared
and i i took this realistic approach to
it
and then i added the unrealistic
sharknados
and all i really did was say to myself
okay what would i do if this actually
happened
and then the difference between this and
a realistic disaster moving
is that when you get to the point where
you say this is ridiculous this could
never happen
this isn't believable this isn't
realistic
you don't worry about that you just keep
going as long as the characters
stay in that reality and address what's
happening to them
in a believable fashion as long as you
as the audience can say
yeah that's what i do if a tornado full
of sharks started coming at me
or at least that's what i would do if i
was really brave
and i was forced to not hide
what would i do if a tornado full of
sharks was coming at me
writing writing sharknado you still have
the same
require dramatic requirements of any
good movie
you still need to develop character it
still needs to go from point a to point
b to point c
the characters need to be in jeopardy
they have to develop as they go along
you have to build suspense you have to
reveal things as you go
you have to reach a climax where it
looks like the the characters are
you know out of luck and they're
gonna die you have to follow all the
same
requirements of good screenwriting you
simply don't have to stop when you get
to the point where it stops
where it would ordinarily stop being
realistic or believable
we get to keep going
so it's a it's it's a real movie
with real characters in an unbelievable
situation
forced to be believable
i think or i could be full of
there's really no telling
so the media storm and the twitter blitz
that ensued
with the first sharknado from having
a father that was a journalist and being
exposed to that industry
what tips did you take away from him or
observe from him that helped you handle
that
viral success interesting
i think growing up with a journalist's
father
and a very proper british mother
i don't know that they actually
prepared me for the specifics of how i
handled
the explosion of interest after
sharknado but what they did was they
gave me
a well-rounded and worldly perception
i was exposed to a lot of different
stuff as a kid
not just the little slice of life
that i would otherwise have grown up in
my father was also a professional wine
critic
so we not only did we have our middle
class life in new york city
not only was i exposed to you know ideas
regarding the world and politics and all
that stuff
but we also uh traveled in um in some
social circles well above our uh
actual financial standings because
as a as a wine critic you're you're sort
of forced into the upper echelons of
society so i really got to see
how ever how the not the just the other
half live but how all the different
haves lived
and i think just having sort of a
well-rounded uh
perception helped keep me from getting
too overwhelmed
during the the attention blitz that
followed
the release of sharknado and the other
thing really that i that i credit
um is simply that i had spent 20 years
trying to get into this business if this
had happened if sharknado had happened
when i was in my mid-20s when i came out
here
intending for something like this to
happen i'd probably be so screwed up
right now i'd probably be a raging ego
maniac
but but years of being humbled
you know being beaten down sort of
banging my head against doors that
wouldn't open for me
i think has helped has helped me keep a
level head during all of this
that and the fact that things like this
just don't happen
uh and and for this to happen even once
is an incredible blessing
and there sure as hell no way i could
expect it to ever happen again so i had
to take
maximum advantage of it when you get an
opportunity you've got to take it for
all it's worth
so if i had just let this go to my head
and i'd gone off and become you know
like a hollywood party person instead of
buckling down and doing every interview
i could and meeting
taking every meeting i could getting an
agent making the most of
out of this professionally that i could
and trying to keep my trying to keep my
own uh my own sense of self
in check and intact
um was vitally
crucial to my perception of my future
progress and future happiness
i'd been working to become an overnight
success for 20 years
and here was my opportunity so if i
screwed this up i'd just have to you
know blow my brains out or something
so i couldn't allow myself
to be overwhelmed or to get carried away
and mind you i've been a bit overwhelmed
and a bit carried away
um but i've
i've been able to temper that you know
and and sometimes doing
a lot of press that that whole first
week
after sharknado came out it's just a
blur
that that night was the most surreal
experience of my life
and then the next morning when i started
getting calls for interviews
um and uh and two days later i was
shooting a segment for good morning
america i mean
you know things like this don't happen
and so i've just tried to enjoy it but
at the same time friends look at me and
say
why aren't you partying why is it why
aren't you jumping for joy
why aren't you just going nuts and i am
but it's on the inside i'm trying to
maintain some kind of
equilibrium because i know that i have
to make the most of this that i possibly
can
if i want to do and be
what i always said i was going to do and
be
what can the fans of the first sharknado
expect
with sharknado the second one uh
sharknado 2 the second one
is basically going to be bigger and
better than the first
on the first one we made a hundred
million dollar film
for less than a million dollars um and
it shows
you know let's not let's not kid
ourselves about that um
at the same time i think the fact that
we were reaching for that
is part of what made it endearing on the
second one
we're making a 200 million dollar film
on um
on again about one percent of the money
we should have
but but by virtue of the fact that it
takes place in new york
and although we didn't think it at the
time
the weather really helped us because we
were shooting a movie that's supposed to
take place in the summer
in february and march of one of the
worst winters the east coast has seen in
recent memory
um and so we were cursing the weather on
a daily basis but it gave us the look
of an extreme weather pattern that
naturally a sharknado would bring
um there's so it's going to feel like a
much bigger
better movie um we knew
that people had taken to the first one
in a certain way
and so we were able to uh guide the
second one
to be what we thought they would want it
to be
so it's not any more tongue-in-cheek and
it's not any more serious than the first
one we still walk that same
line but we
reveled in the sense of glee and
fun that i think the first one evoked
and so anybody who really liked the
first one
is going to love the second one and the
people who hated
the first one and who said it was the
worst movie ever made
won't be able to say that about the
second one but i think they'll still
have fun
interacting with it the way they did the
first one do you have a message for the
twitter
people out there anything do you want to
convey
i hope everybody on twitter just has the
same fun with this one that they did
with the first one
and uh and i hope they take it to their
hearts
um because that's that's why we're here
if it weren't for the the folks on
twitter you know we wouldn't be here
doing this
um so this this is uh this is for you
you